وضع قطر للحرب في اوكرانيا وخطوط حمر كي
لا تخرج عن السيطره فكرتان تلخصان الرؤيه
الامريكيه للحرب في اوكرانيا ربما حتى قبل
نشوبها
جولات عديده اجراها مسؤولون في اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جوبيد طافوا خلالها
العواصم الاوروبيه لابلاغ رساله واضحه
الحرب على وشك ان تبدا وعلى الجميع ان
يستعد لدعم اوكرانيا سياسيا وماليا
وعسكريا
وبالفعل اثمرت وقتها الجهود في بدء تدفق
السلاح على اوكرانيا كي تكون جاهزه على
الاقل لصد الموجه الاولى من الهجوم
واليوم بعد مرور اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر على
الحرب باتت الرسائل والمحادثات السريه
ضروريه ايضا كي تحافظ واشنطن على ما بدات
اداره بيض تطلب من كيف ان تظهر الايجابيه
فيما يتعلق بفكره التفاوض مع موسكو بينما
تتكفل هي بمحادثات سريه خلف الكواليس مع
الدائره المقربه من بوتن خوفا من الكابوس
الذي لن يتحمله احد وهو استخدام السلاح
النوويه
لصحيفه
ان مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيكسون
اجرى محادثات لم يتم الكشف عنها مع كبار
المسؤولين الروس
للدقه اكثر مع نظيره نيكولاي بتروشيف
سكرتيره مجلس الامن الروسي
مساعد الرئيس الروسي والهدف الحد من خاطر
امتداد الحرب في اوكرانيا او تصعيدها الى
صراع النبويه
حتى الان يصر الرئيس بلاديمير بوتين على
انه لا داعي لاستخدام السلاح النووي
للتكتيكي ولا الاستراتيجيه في الحرب لكن
المراقبين يرون ان هذا الامر
رهن بتطورات المعركه ويرتبط بشكل وثيق
بخطه واشنطن الاولى بمعنى اخر الوصول الى
نهايه للحرب لا يكون فيها رابح كامل ولا
خاسر كامل لان روسيا اذا استشعرت انها
ستخسر كل شيء حينها قد يظهر الرعب النووي